[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es den
klassiker nämlich frittierte donath es
hat sich immer so ab turner mäßig und
wenn jemand sagt kritisiert aber bei
donuts bin ich echt ein fan von
frittieren das muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen ist einfach so wenn man denkt ja
fertig und so auf jeden fall und das
komische ist wenn ich so viel selber
frittiert dann wird mir bewusst ja ok
skizziert aber wenn ich die draußen esse
ich aber nicht also haben wir das auch
schon mal geklärt hier direkt direkt
hier im statement direkt rausgehauen
nicht so genau
ihr müsst es genau weil donuts meinung
sollten auch frittiert sein es gibt
natürlich mit sicherheit eine gesündere
variante wenn ihr möchtet dann zeige ich
euch die auch er mache ich sie
vielleicht mal backofen schreibt mir das
einfach mal hier unten in die kommentare
aber heute gibt es die klassischen wie
bei dunkin donuts
so haben wir es und jetzt zeige ich euch
hier direkt die zutaten für den
donnerstag das ist immer ein klassischer
hefe teilt und da habe ich jetzt mein
mail in meiner großen glasschüssel der
küchenmaschine könnte es auch mit den
händen kneten und was ich euch jetzt
direkt an tipps geben kann ich leg
direkt los ich habe hier ein bisschen
mehl also 50 gramm mehl habe ich hier
zur seite gelegt es gebe ich noch nicht
rein
es kommt nämlich auf die größe oder auf
das volumen der eier an wie viel mehr im
endeffekt reinkommt 500 gramm sind hier
schon in meiner schüsse und wie gesagt
50 einmal an die seite legen
jetzt mache ich hier eine kleine mulde
direkt in der schüssel gibt da die milch
rhein ganz wichtig die muss lauf am sein
darf aber auch nicht über 40 grad seien
38 grad war perfekt und dann einmal in
die mitte der mode reingeben und da
bröseln wir die frische hefe mit hinein
können auch trocken hilfe nehmen
schreibt euch alles eben die video
beschreibung und dann auch noch so
ungefähr zwei teelöffel zucker als
nahrung für die hefe
[Musik]
so und jetzt zugedeckt zehn minuten
ruhen lassen wird cdu und später hat er
durfte jetzt die hefe schild arbeiten
und ich habe auch extra ein bisschen
zucker dazu rücken immer rezept haben
wir insgesamt ein bisschen mehr zucker
aber wir wollen die hefe ja nicht in
zucker ertrinken quasi daher reicht ja
das jetzt definitiv aus und jetzt gebe
ich alle anderen zutaten mit dazu und
kniete das heute mal in der
küchenmaschine mit dem knethaken hier
können ja wie ich schon erwähnt habe
euch eure hände benutzen mache ich auch
ganz gerne bei hefeteig einmal zucker zu
schoko ja dann haben wir hier butter
ganz wichtig schmerzt sie und lasst sie
aus können die darf nicht heiß sein gibt
auch noch mit dazu
jetzt kommen alle zutaten zeige ich euch
jetzt nach und nach um wie gesagt immer
bei mir immer in der video beschreibung
ganz easy habe ich hier zwei eier
wir sollten auch auf zimmertemperatur
seien also nicht ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank
das wäre ideal so jetzt werdet ihr euch
wundern salzstocks alt und diesmal auch
viel nicht nur eine prise wie es sonst
kennt von mir sondern einen gestrichenen
teelöffel das zeige ich euch das ist
ungefähr so viel das sind 4 gramm
die kommen auch dach ein
[Musik]
als spiegel mega praktisch zu einem
laien
ich habe heute einfach nur bad hair day
ist es so wie es ist sie haben mit
zugebunden kannst ja auch ganz gut und
mit knete ich mein hefeteig per hand
weiter weil dann könnt ihr entscheiden
wie viel mir da noch reingehört
ich habe jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
näher eingegeben wichtig ist halt das
denn nicht mehr kleben darf und er muss
so ein bisschen widerstand noch haben
wir das auch nicht zu fest sein aber es
zeige ich euch gleich am besten jetzt
habe ich den teig zwei bis drei minuten
lang weiter geknetet und der ist jetzt
so perfekt also ihr drücken und da gibt
es ein bisschen widerstand und so muss
er auch sein und es ist echt so dass er
manchmal 530 gramm ihr braucht manchmal
55 gramm
man müsste einfach selber schauen und
nach gefühl arbeiten und jetzt gebe ich
hier ein bisschen back trend spray auf
den boden einer schüssel
die braucht er und auswaschen wieso ich
jetzt keinen mehr dazu gibt es dann
einfach folgenden grund ich möchte nicht
dass der teig unnötig austrocknet weil
gleich beim ausrollen gebe ich auch noch
mal mehr dazu deswegen möchte ich hier
auch beim jahr beim aufgehen kein mehl
dazugeben und gebe jetzt gern das bak
transfer obendrauf noch damit es nicht
austrocknet und jetzt zugedeckt 45
minuten lang ruhen lassen bis sich der
teig verdoppelt so ihr leben nach der
ruhezeit ist der teig deutlich
aufgegangen und ich nehme jetzt die
saubere arbeitsfläche gibt etwas mehr
drunter und gebt dem teig obendrauf
diesmal nehme ich meine aus rahlstedt
die sind hier zehn zentimeter dick und
das mache ich bei diesem rezept aus dem
grund damit ich weiß okay die werden
alle gleich groß sie sehen alle gleich
aus die brauchen auch gleich lang im
fett und deswegen habe ich sie ebenso
ausgerollt und jetzt nimmt er euch zwei
hunde ausstecher oder zum beispiel auch
eine tasse oder was auch immer ihr da
habt so ungefähr 8 bis 8 5 zentimeter
sollte dann euer donath großteil der
kann auch mini donuts machen das auch
euch überlassen
ich mache heute klassischen und innen
das sind glaube ich so ungefähr
zweieinhalb zentimeter und ich stehe
jetzt einfach mal ein paar donuts aus
und legt sie dann auf die mieter
arbeitsfläche und bedeckte sie dann
direkt mit einem sauberen küchentuch
[Musik]
den ausgestochenen donath eick jetzt
noch mal 30 bis 45 minuten lang
abgedeckt gehen lassen wenn wir 45
minuten zeit habe dann nehmt euch die
zeit gerne aber in der zeit geht es noch
mal auf und das bewegen dass sie so
schön fluffig werden und anschließend
einfach frittierfett erhitzen entweder
nimmt ihr euch einen tiefen topf oder
breiten topf oder eine tiefe und breite
bahnen also ob ich das heute gemacht und
heute nämlich distelöl das ist besten
trage zum frittieren
ansonsten geht denke ich auch rapsöl
schaut auf jeden fall ob zum frittieren
geeignet ist und es muss man eben
geschmacksneutral sein das ist ganz klar
und jetzt ganz ganz ganz wichtig wie
lange muss ich das frittieren es ist
echt immer unterschiedlich selbst bei
mir jetzt also die ersten haben glaube
ich eineinhalb minuten gebraucht dann
gegen die anderen waren nach einer
minute schon fertig ihr müsst immer
schauen
ich zeige euch jetzt hier auch mal
beispiele die hier sind ein ticken zu
dunkel gewesen
das kommt auch wirklich auf 23 sekunden
an und den perfekten donath habe ich
hier ganz vielleicht auch noch mal
scharf stellen dass man nicht also das
ist meiner meinung nach der perfekte
donath schön hell nicht zu dunkel das öl
darf eben nicht zu heiß sein dass das
fett eben nicht wer den donut verbrennt
es darf nicht zu kalt sein damit der
hefeteig das ganze nicht einzieht und
was wir auch gezeigt haben dass
wahrscheinlich die stäbchen probe schön
aufgenommen haben war das heißt einfach
einen schaschlikspieß in euro und wenn
kein zwang von blasen aufsteigen dann
ist es perfekt und die temperatur misst
erhalten immer mal niedriger stellen man
höre ich hab jetzt immer stufe 5 und 6
genommen und dann sind wir eigentlich
auch schon fertig jetzt fehlt eigentlich
nur noch der schokolade großen rückruf
ja ich mich auch dann noch mal
ganz klassisch ist ja voll mit glasur
dafür nimmt ihr am besten temperierte
schokolade das macht ihr folgendermaßen
ganz easy ihr nehmt euch ein wasserbad
das heißt einfach ein bisschen was
seinem topf aufkochen lassen
eine feuerfeste schüssel obendrauf geben
nimmt ihr euch auch nicht kaputt geht da
gibt er dann zwei drittel eurer
kuvertüre reinigt natürlich voll mit
korrekturen
wir können auch zart peter oder weiße
nehmen dass das tier dann schmelzen
sobald es geschmolzen ist einfach vom
topf herunternehmen dann das restliche
drittel dazu geben
eine rest hitze schmelzen lassen und
zack habt ihr die perfekte temperierte
schokolade beziehungsweise kuvertüre
kein grauschleier die glänzt wunderbar
da muss kein fett oder so was rein und
wir können anfangen die oberfläche der
donuts ja einfach da rein zu tun nicht
mehr als einfach mal ein punkt den hier
kurz zur hälfte rein lasst ihn gut
abtropfen
denn dass sich das auch noch mal aus
herten
[Musik]
und wir können noch bunte donuts machen
beim kindergeburtstag zum beispiel blaue
pink lila grüne alles was ihr möchtet
und was ich mir überlegt abschnitt euch
doch gerne kenny mails die habe ich auch
im shop verlinke ich euch genauso wie
alles andere um die info-box und die
nehme ich jetzt weil weiße schokolade
isst er b statt weiß und kälte neben
weise nicht fragen ganz ganz viele wie
kriege ich weiße schokolade hin fast
unmöglich aber nimmt dann die cannibals
einmal rein tun ich schnell das ganze
jetzt gleich in der mikrowelle und dann
habe ich mir überlegt ob ich dann noch
bunte streusel oben drauf und dann
einfach mal schauen wie es optisch
aussieht das jetzt könnt da ganz wild
herum experimentieren
[Musik]
jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel freude
beim nachbacken der donut die exakt wie
bei dunkin donuts schmecken aber es geht
natürlich ganz ganz viele varianten es
gibt ja oder nein gibt es gefüllte
donuts was machst du am liebsten
gefüllte mit etwas mit wenn du dir
bestimmt vanillepudding posten cream in
gott wir müssen unbedingt mit 100
rezepte machen also schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare was nicht fehlen darf
also und zeigen euch auch die füllung
und das äußere und alles drum und dran
bruce a hans wicki auf jeden fall
wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel freude
beim nachbacken die schmecken wirklich
unglaublich lecker die die glasur es
jetzt nicht ganz angezogen ich bin mir
gleich auf jeden fall ein paar kann es
auch gern problemen
ja natürlich macht die römer wirklich
die mühe damit ich nur einen einzigen es
ja ich bin sagt nein
das gibt's nicht wir probieren am besten
gleich wie probieren auf instagram okay
wenn wir uns auf instagram noch nicht
folgen ganz dringend einmal nachholen da
seht ihr dann immer tiefer was es bei
zugibt und ja ansonsten wünsche euch zum
dritten mal gleicht schon ganz viel
freude und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
ich weiss man loggt sich selber nicht
macht wenn ich so gehört sich das
ganz ehrlich die schmecken besser als
bei dunkin donuts die schmecken einfach
nur so gut unbedingt nachmachen mir dass
ich macht nach macht selber schuld